today are the good old days I know stop
reminiscing about the good old days
because you are living in a good old day
right now this is basically the therapy
I had this morning at eight o'clock my
father is in his mid 70s and we'll talk
about good old days from 10 years ago
when he was in his mid 60s and we're 30
years away from that I said sing it
sister I'm I long for the past I have
trouble being present and I Fear the
Future
and and that's not a good place that you
want to be and even when I I dig deep I
dig my heels into the fact that right
now is the Nostalgia I then get anxiety
because it's just slipping through my
fingers in the moment and that's I think
in the words of Elsa from Frozen Let It
Go
[Music]
what a battle lobotomy